we did nothing wrong nothing wrong
whatsoever we did absolutely nothing
wrong take a look at the presidential
records act we did it by the book
perfect except we have Thugs and creeps
running this country right it's a real
problem for our country we're going to
straighten it away we're going to win
the election big and we're going to
clean up the mess and we're going to
clean up the cancer because that's what
we have
a very strong somebody in the back is
like uh does this mean it's gonna take a
while to get my maple syrup
um what a strange I mean there's a level
of pomposity with just going through a
place where people are having breakfast
and starting to rant and Rave about you
did nothing wrong I did nothing wrong